[Music]
so
good evening i love seeing all these
faces
really i can't tell you how much it
warms my heart to see you guys here
welcome to the table my name is karen
miner so glad you're here
here and also glad that those of you are
online are joining us
as well if you are joining us online
please
comment let us know where you're
watching from we would love to be able
to welcome you personally
and one of our members james townsend is
going to be
hosting online on our live stream so i
just have a couple of announcements
tonight before we get started
uh speaking of online we just launched a
brand new online meetup
and they had their first meeting last
wednesday night
and from what i've heard it went really
really well and people tuned in from
tennessee
california florida all over texas
um so you know while those of us are
meeting here
uh there are some that still aren't able
to meet yet in person
and there are some that are looking for
an inclusive church
that don't have one near them and so if
that's you
or if you know somebody if you're
watching online that would be a great
way to get connected here at the table
so if you're interested or you know
someone if you're here in this room you
can come up and talk to me and i'll give
you information
after the service or if you're watching
online you can comment
and james will give you the information
about that but
again it's a great way to get connected
with the table and we would love to have
you
secondly uh happy pride month to
everyone
yes uh and i think most of you know that
brett
is off this month we really value rest
at the table making sure that our
leaders get breaks so they don't get
burned out
and that's especially true for our
lead pastor he works extremely hard and
so
he gets the sundays off this month it's
a win-win because we get to have
wonderful guest speakers
that join us throughout the month and
but brett is still here in spirit and
he had some words that he shared on
social media as pride month kicked off
and i thought they were really really
good and they really
expressed the heart of our mission our
values and
our leadership team here at the table so
i wanted to share them with you
to my friends in the lgbtqi plus
community
you are dearly loved just as you are
i'm sorry for the way christians and
churches have operated from a place of
at best deep misunderstanding and fear
and at worst the desire to humiliate and
exclude
as a christian pastor my prayer is that
this year
you would find the inner healing that
you need and want
that the years of shame would be washed
away by the embrace of a loving god
that the years of hiding would be
restored through a community that says
you have nothing to hide
your name is not broken or ruined your
name
is known and loved may you walk in that
truth
will you join me in prayer god thank you
for tonight
thank you that you are here with us
thank you that we are surrounded by your
love
and goodness always thank you that we
can also
always find home with you god and i pray
that you would open our eyes and ears
tonight
as we worship and listen and
be together god and i just thank you
for all of the wonders and expressions
of love that are around us
in jesus name i pray amen
[Music]
guys we're about to start our worship
but i just full disclosure
okay this is what i've learned full
disclosure we are among friends
we are run among friends that sometimes
aren't here actually i'm
very excited i kept trying to get
lance's attention while ago and i was
doing this
and you weren't listening or looking
you're probably paying attention to
karen good for you
but i'm really excited to have some
friends that aren't usually here with us
and tonight as we go into worship we've
had like
sickness and we've had band members that
weren't able to make it and we've had
internet that wasn't working when we got
here and it's just been kind of one of
those crazy
the shows you know that phrase that we
use
sometimes that one that one that you're
thinking of
okay and so i was just talking
with gary and noel while ago and
reminding myself like we
are singing songs to god with friends
that's what we're doing that's what
worship is
it's not actually as fancy and like
glorified as sometimes i want to make it
in my mind
um or actually that is the glorified
part about it
it's just that we get to come together
and sing songs to god so will you guys
stand with us
and join us in our hodgepodge messy
worship set because that's what we're
about to jump into yes
all right i really need you guys to sing
along with me if you can't so yeah
gary's voice is like
hanging on by a thread if you hear us
switching around from harmony to melody
parts that's what's happening
so all right there we go lord i
find you in the seeking
lord i find you
in the doubt and to
know
[Music]
i need you
oh how i need you
oh i need you
[Music]
lord i find you in the
seeking lord i find you
in the doubt and to know
you is to love you and to know
[Music]
oh how i need you
know how i need you
[Music]
lord i find you in the morning lord i
seek you
[Music]
of grace i need you
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
light glorious light i will go away you
shine break the dawn
crack the scratch make the way right
before me
in your life i will find all i need
all i need is you
[Music]
is
oh
how i need you
oh how i need you
for how i need you
[Music]
how's that for messi yeah that's about
how i expected it to go so
a little rough guys you're a trooper
gary you're a trooper all right
let's do king of my heart
[Music]
let the king of my heart
be the mountain where i run
the fountain
[Music]
oh
you are good you're good
[Music]
let the king of my heart be
the wind inside myself
he
[Music]
the is in the waves oh
he is
[Music]
oh
you're never
[Music]
you're never gonna let me
you're never gonna let me down
[Music]
last time
you're never gonna let me down
[Music]
oh
you're never going to let me down
you are good you're good
[Music]
is
like glorious light i will go
where you shine break the dawn
crack the sky make the way right before
me in your life
i will find all i need all i need is
[Music]
you
jesus thank you that you care about us
[Music]
thank you that we can be amongst friends
and sing songs that talk about a god
who is with us who is not far
who though we may call you king is also
our friend
[Music]
who walks through the valleys
and the mountains god
[Music]
we're going to take some time because he
is a god that cares to go into
a prayer of the people if this is your
first time here i'm gonna read through
a prayer and at the end of each line i
think the words are in a different color
um the the line says we pray to you at
the end and if you guys would like to
join in with us
as we say that line and then after a
moment
i will leave some space for us to speak
out
um the name of someone that maybe your
heart is heavy for or someone that you
know needs a little bit extra
love or grace or goodness in their life
right now
or maybe it's a people group or a
situation going on in this world
that has been heavy on your heart and so
it's just a time for us to speak those
out together
and believe that the god who is with us
is listening
and cares um and and just to send
positivity and love out towards those
people
um and then i'll close us up with a
short prayer at the end of that as well
so you guys join in as you would like
this is an old tradition
um in a lot of other liturgies and we
have loved making it a part of our
service and really joining together in
this moment and being active
participants and not just
onlookers um but joining in together
all as a body for this city of saxi
texas and for every city and community
and all of those who live in them
we pray to you for the good earth that
you have given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you for those who travel
on land and sea or air
we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the widow and the
orphan
for the injured and the suffering we
pray
to you for the poor and oppressed
the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and
captives and for all who remember and
care for them
we pray to you lord we know that you
love us
and that you hear us and so now we lift
these names and situations
up to you and if you're joining us
online feel free to leave a comment
and karen will be watching our live feed
and she can share those names as well
so go ahead
jaden
[Music]
from online we have alex
and we have anna marie
for kids who do not have a home
from online lauren
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
[Music]
when you walk into the room
everything changes
the darkness starts to tremble at the
light
that you bring and when you walk
into the room every heart starts burning
and nothing matters more than just to
sit here at your feet
we love you
we'll never stop we can't
live without you
jesus we
love you we can't get enough
all this is for you
[Music]
jesus
when you walk into the room
sickness starts to vanish every hopeless
situation
ceases to exist when you walk into the
room
the dead begin to rise cause there is
[Music]
resurrection
we love you
but we'll never stop we can't
live without you
jesus we
love you we can't get enough
hope this is for you
jesus
come and consume and come and consume
god
oh we are we give you permission our
hearts are yours we want you
[Music]
we want you to come and consume god oh
we are we give you permission our hearts
are yours we want you
[Music]
we give you permission our hearts are
yours
our hearts are yours
love you we'll never stop
we can't live without you
jesus we love you oh
we can't get enough hope
this is for you jesus
we love you
we'll never stop we can't live without
you
jesus we love you
i can't get it
is for you jesus
[Music]
jesus
yes god
thank you for being here in our midst
[Music]
in our mess in our authenticity god
we just invite you in
[Music]
we love you and we love this time
together
so thank you for it it's a gift may we
be light
and encouragement to one another in the
world around us
it's in your name we pray these things
[Music]
amen
thank you guys so much for bearing with
us through all of that
all the ups and downs if you all would
turn to each other and just greet each
other and then karen's gonna go ahead
and
kick us off and get going
all right well i have the very great
pleasure and honor
of introducing our guest speaker for
tonight
uh what can you guys welcome erin as he
comes up here come on up
come on up yeah
okay bro i love erin the best
so aaron as you could tell is a little
taller than me
he is slightly um aaron
is a pastor a counselor a psychologist
a gifted singer and tennis player
devoted husband
uh what else comic-con fan i think
that's enough
i feel good i feel very good about me
right now thank you
he's also a dear friend of many of us
here at the table
and uh aaron and lance have both
really encouraged our elder team and has
given
they've just given us countless pieces
of wisdom
perspective love encouragement support
championing when we needed it the most
especially as we were transitioning from
our old church
to launching the table and i mean we're
eternally grateful for that you guys
are such a huge part of the table even
though
to many you're they're just seeing your
faces for the first time
but i can't say enough about aaron
about his husband lance and just the
amazing men of god that they are
and during covid when aaron's church
was doing online services as well they
had their services on sunday evenings
too
and so i would often hop off our live
stream and then hop onto their live
stream so i could listen and watch and
be a part of that as i was cooking
dinner
and i always left those messages feeling
like god is love
god is good and god is with me
and i don't think you can get any better
or more gospel
than that so um i'm just so glad you're
here you also have like my favorite
uh message title of all time
can i feel free okay i'm gonna say this
in church
it was the best and it was a great
message it was called your racist ass
amygdala and it was all about how
your brain is wired certain anyways it
was amazing
it's still online if you want to watch
it how about with that let me pray
there we go oh
god thank you thank you so much for
aaron thank you
for his heart for you god that he is a
disciple of yours
jesus and that he models his life after
you
i thank you for the words he's going to
share with us tonight
and i thank you god that you have
something for each one of us personally
from the words that he's going to share
so i just pray your blessings over him
fill them up with your spirit and we're
just
joyful and overjoyed that he's here
tonight in jesus name i pray
amen amen thanks karen i already feel so
much
apart oh i have my very special clicker
in my pocket thank you
i already feel very much a part of this
community i have for about three years
now ever since i've met lance
everyone has always been so welcoming
and made me such a part of what was
already happening
so i don't feel like i'm speaking at a
different church i feel like i'm
speaking at a church i've been a part of
for a very long time
um but some of you haven't had a chance
to meet me yet and i haven't had a
chance to meet you
um i think my sermons are bizarre enough
that by the end of it she'll know me
very well
um so with that let's go ahead and get
started
or not there we go handy clicker thank
you um so
matthew chapter 5 verses 43-45
starting off jesus's words you have
heard that it was said
you shall love your neighbor and hate
your enemy but
i say to you love your enemies and pray
for those who persecute you
so that you may be sons of your father
who is in heaven
for he causes his son to rise on the
evil and the good
and sends rain on the righteous and the
unrighteous
handy clickers not working well
it's my name
we got next one no there we go all right
four if you love those who love you what
reward do you have
do not even tax collectors do the same
if you greet only your brothers
what more are you doing than others
do not even gentiles do the same
therefore
you are to be perfect as your heavenly
father is perfect okay this is the very
first part of the sermon today where
you're going to get to see how
weirdly wired my brain is because
i read that verse this week getting
ready for this sermon and this is what
came to mind
white truth i will tell you why for
those of you who watch the offer that
are already laughing here's what
happened
dwight goes to this convention delivers
this speech that makes
no sense uh he's taken famous manifestos
of speeches from all sorts
of people and just strung them together
delivers it with all sorts of passion
and people just cheer for them
and at the end of i go but did you hear
anything that the man actually
said so i read these verses
from jesus and i go here christianity is
growing over all these years
people love being christians i love
jesus i'm a follower of jesus
did you hear any of the words that the
man
said so i've read there are 45
000 different christian denominations
over 300 alone in the u.s we're trying
to figure out
who's in who's out what is the thing
that we have to do how do we do baptisms
right
is it okay if you did it as a kid do i
have to do it again as an adult if i
join a new church do i also have to get
baptized there
what should i do and i'm like you should
probably listen to the words of the man
you say you follow
that might be a fantastic start so what
did jesus say makes you a child of god
really simple um should be one more
right before that
if not i'll probably just mess it up but
either way jesus starts really simple
and
highlights the words that's i have
highlighted for you the worst it says
therefore you're gonna be perfect as
your heavenly father is perfect
what is it that makes the heavenly
father perfect he loves everybody
he loves the good he loves the bad his
reign shines on the good and the bad
that means not only does he love both
groups of people
he gives to both groups of people so if
here it is if you want to be like your
heavenly father thank you
um love your enemies pray for those who
persecute you so that you may be
sons of your father who is in heaven
that's
all it means to be a child of god jesus
made it that
simple for us um so how have we missed
the point so badly
why do we have so many denominations how
do we have so many church splits over
who's in and who's out
and god says everybody's obviously in
and it's kind of like jesus going just
look at the world
and this is obvious does the sun shine
on the good and the bad
yes do the good and the bad get rain
yeah like if you look around at the
world that part is obvious
who do you think is doing those things
that's god
so therefore this seems to be a really
simple
message however we have a hard time with
it and i think that's why we spend so
much time spinning our wheels
how do all these things work out how
does everything that paul said didn't
match up with what jesus said
all of these things we're spinning our
wheels because it's a simple concept
that is really complex to put into
action
so what we're going to try to do today
is take the first step
of putting this into action and i think
this is why we've missed the boat
the first thing we're going to talk
about today is what i call our first
forgiveness
one more so our first forgiveness
is this idea that we have to forgive the
world for not being the thing that we
wanted it to be
so much of our religious practice has to
do with correcting the world back to the
way that we think it should be
people all need to act this way because
my life would sure be easier if they did
and so we're constantly telling people
who they should be
how they should act this is how things
have to be done
because i have a hard time tolerating
the world as is this is why we
have so many denominations because i
can't tolerate the fact that you do
baptism this way i can't tolerate the
fact that you wear your hair this way
you let your ankles out oh god we can't
tolerate the world being something other
than what it is and so i think this is
what jesus is really getting at here
this is the world when jesus says the
kingdom of heaven is here
we have a hard time with that message
again so we make it all these things
like the secret kingdom of heaven and
the hidden
kingdom of heaven is here but like what
if this is just it
and maybe the kingdom of heaven is just
not quite what we want it to be
so god is saying all these people are
here you have opportunities to love each
other to be one with each other
people do some good things and some bad
things and maybe
that's just what you get and we have to
learn to work within this system instead
of hoping that one day
this all gets destroyed and replaced
with the really good system that god
really meant to do but we kind of messed
up
we learned to live within what god has
given us
i also take this concept from the ten
commandments
so if you know the ten commandments the
first four are all about how we relate
to god
so when it switches from how we relate
to god to how we relate to people
the first commandment is honor your
father and mother that your days may be
prolonged in the land which the lord god
gives you
so this concept of honor your father and
mother is really difficult because the
idea of honoring what does that mean
and for me when i grew up and i was in
sunday school and people said honor your
father and mother i was like yeah
i totally get that that's a great idea
some people
have fathers and mothers who were
terribly abusive and did all sorts of
things to them
so what does it mean to honor and this
is
what i think when we're young when we're
toddlers just young young kids
everything is just an object
you are an object for my safety you are
an object for milk
you are an object for transportation
everything is just an object and as we
grow up
hopefully we come to the point where we
start to see people as human beings and
not just objects for our pleasure
so when you look at the rest of the
sermon on the mount and jesus is talking
about
don't lust don't call people a fool and
all those things
jesus is saying don't make people an
object for your consumption
they don't need to be smart so you can
feel good they don't need to understand
everything you say
they don't need to make you feel good
with how they look they're not an object
for your consumption
as we grow up we learn to to love people
strictly for the human dignity that they
already have
this starts with our parents because our
parents are the people who we have the
most expectation for
they were the biggest objects we had and
as we grow up
hopefully we learned to look at them as
people who have some good
some bad did them some things really
well
mess some things up really bad and we
love them for who they
are but too often we love them either
because we think they're perfect
or as you go through those rebellious
teenage years now all of a sudden they
can't do
anything right everything is wrong but
the truth is we don't need them to be
perfect
we don't need them to have all the
knowledge and all the wisdom as we grow
up we learn to just love them for who
they are
and that's really our first forgiveness
it starts with our parents and ourselves
and i think we have to start spreading
to the world richard rohr puts it this
way
our first forgiveness is not toward a
particular sin
or offense our first forgiveness it
seems to me
is toward reality itself to forgive it
for being so
broken a mixture of good
and bad and if you know your sunday
school stories
um the book of jonah is all
about this concept um but i need you to
kind of forget some of your sunday
school jonah which is all just about big
fish because
anything that has an animal gets told in
sunday school like
like forget the fact that like god
killed everybody let's tell this story
to children that's fantastic
like if it has an animal we tell it if
that is cool
but today i am going to tell you the
real story
of jonah and so i have archaeological
records
this is what the real jonah looked like
this my friends is jonah snow and
god came to jonah and god says jonah i
want you to go
up to the ninevites and
you are going to preach to the ninevites
that
they need to repent or destruction
is coming jonah's like no i'm not going
to do it they killed my dad they killed
my brother i'm out on this
so he's like nope we'll not be going in
i'm going south
um eventually jonah ends up getting on a
boat
if you think i'm like just kind of
joking about this whole boat this is
from pirates of the caribbean this is
real like in the story the boat actually
talks like the boat thinks about whether
or not it's going to break up
so jonah gets on this boat he's sailing
off
a big huge storm comes everybody else on
the boat is like throwing sacrifices to
their god like
one of us has to be the one jonah's the
only one left he's still sleeping
finally the boat starts going down and
jonah's like this i regret nothing
not not even a letter i regret nothing
i'm out um so the fun part of the story
that we all know
uh jonah meets the huge fish he's like
hey beasty
he's in the belly of the beast for three
days so finally at some point
jonah gives up and is like fine i will
go to nineveh
jonah preaches the worst sermon you've
ever heard
like literally go read jonah it's the
worst sermon you will ever read
jonah's just like repent or god's gonna
kill you
and they all do like they're just
repeating
left and right everybody in nineveh
like even joffrey is like ready to
repent
like everybody has
repented and this is the entire
fun and the satire of the story if you
read jonah really well
everybody else asks for forgiveness and
everybody else seeks it and gives it
except the one guy who was supposed to
be the man of god
jonah at the end of the story is still
like this i'm tired of this church
i'm out and what is jonomatic jonah is
mad because the world
was not what jonah wanted it to be and
jonah had more expectation of anybody
i'm one of the people of god
people don't get to mess with us
our god delivered us out of the land of
egypt our god destroys our enemies and
makes sure that
nothing bad ever happens and jonah
doesn't know what to happen
what to do when that's not the way the
world actually works
this is a fantastic message for us who
grew up
in american christianity because we had
more expectation for how the world would
be
than just about anybody we thought our
parents were supposed to be perfect
our parents were never supposed to cheat
they were never supposed to lie they
were never supposed to mess up
other people were always supposed to be
so nice and kind
and if we did a kind gesture they were
supposed to immediately recognize it
because i have been nice
um we grow up with all this expectation
that we grow up to be adults and we
don't know what to do with
and we end up doing just one of a couple
things either we just kind of live in
denial and we just keep saying the
world's going to become what i want it
to be
or we start living in rebellion we kind
of go past down this path of
deconstruction which i think can be
really good
but we start going down it and now all
of a sudden we just hate everything
and everything's bad and nothing's worth
doing and
no group of people are worth being
around like we just can't get out of it
like so the world's
not what i want to be i will either deny
that or i will sulk in it
but we don't really know how to get out
okay so let's really discuss the concept
of forgiveness because forgiveness is
hard like it's forgiving excusing the
thing
is it accepting the thing i found this
on psychology today i think it's a
good way of viewing it forgiveness is a
decision to let the past be
what it is to leave it as
is imperfect and not what we wish
it had been forgiveness means that we
stop the shoulda coulda woulda beens and
relinquish the idea
that we can create a different or better
past
because we can't in all honesty the best
thing we have right now is even
creating a better future i can't change
my current present
i could walk out right now i guess but
right now i'm still here so i can't even
immediately change
my present and so forgiveness is that
concept
i will accept where i am i cannot go
back and change the past
let's look at what forgiveness is not
it's not
excusing so that doesn't mean that i say
that everything is okay
in fact excusing is much closer to the
old way of being
so if i think that everything has to be
happy that's my old view of the world
and i'm upset because god hasn't made a
world that's only happy
then what i'll do is i'll excuse things
i don't actually forgive them
i excuse them because now i can just go
back to being happy again
also forgiveness is not passive so
forgiveness means that we honor and we
recognize our anger
we honor and recognize our hurt our
passion
all of those things are still included
in forgiveness so this is
not just some apathetic everything is
fine now
and then also forgiveness is not
self-pity
so it's not everything is terrible
everything bad happens to me and i
accept that
but i'll move on that is not forgiveness
either absolutely not
um but this is the key forgiveness
allows me to see the world or reality
clearly so that i can respond protect
and correct properly so
when so to speak i'm still in my
feelings i can't see the world right
and we've all seen this like we've know
the person who has just started going to
therapy
and you say and they've just kind of
started recognizing some emotional
things going on and you say hello and
they're like
i am setting a boundary and it's like
are we setting a boundary on greeting
each other that's really weird
[Laughter]
but they're trying to learn these good
things like how to defend myself how to
set boundaries and all these things
but they're still totally acting out of
their pain
so part of what forgiveness does is lets
us see clearly
so i can see someone clearly and go i
really love this person and i want to
hang
out with them and i want them to be a
part of my group i'm never going to give
them money if i need it back
because i know what they do and that can
just be reality and forgiveness allows
me to accept the reality
so i'm not pretending that everything is
happy and joy joyce i'll give it to
amino and just be okay
probably not a great decision um
i don't have to be mad at them for
asking i can just move on
knowing what reality is
okay so why is forgiveness so hard i
think this is really key
forgiveness is hard because we still
haven't received
what we wanted or needed i.e security
affirmation understanding the debt still
hasn't been paid
and so generally someone has hurt us in
some way the world being the way it is
even god i'm hurt because i thought god
would protect me from these things
the reason i can't move on and i can't
forgive is because
i still haven't received the sense of
security i need
i still feel lost in this world i don't
feel like people affirm me or understand
me
and so i can't move on and we'll try to
play all the mental gymnastics well it's
okay
they couldn't help it they didn't mean
it and sometimes i think we really mean
those things
the problem is we aren't able to forgive
yet because we're still
lacking anything that we're looking for
and so i think the big step
in forgiveness is basically learning to
be like a big lizzo song all the time
um love yourself be your own soul mate
provide all those things
uh but to be more specific it's really
by learning to give ourselves what we
needed and paying the debt to ourselves
so when you've been hurt and look at
even big broad sweeping things about the
world that hurt you because i think we
all just kind of have them
um i'm naturally very friendly i like
strangers
i don't like the fact that other people
don't just love strangers too
um like yeah like we're best friends now
right like we may not see each other
tomorrow but that's okay we're besties
um and that's that's the hard thing for
me to deal with like that's a big
life concept that's hard for me to deal
with but there's also smaller
someone ignored me um someone who i'm
really close with
did something that hurt me when i get
ready to take the step of forgiveness
for any of those things
i have to look inward and go what's the
thing that i'm still missing
is that thing still making me feel
insecure is it still making me feel
unaffirmed in who i
am any of those things i think this even
goes to our huge fight that you see
within churches
um dealing with lgbtq people um
some people want to be affirmed for who
they are
this group of people want to be affirmed
for what we've always been told and what
we've always believed
and at some point i think we can find
room for everybody very easily
once we get to the point of i can feel
affirmed in what i believe
i can feel affirmed in who i am and all
of these things and that now allows me
to give
real forgiveness and that forgiveness
allows me to sit in the room with you
know you love you and all of those
things but it takes a lot to go through
and just kind of identify
these are the problems that i'm having
that i'm feeling
that now i need to deal with because if
i don't i will still always expect that
other person to do it and be a little
upset
when they don't there's just no getting
past it
okay so then this is my idea of really
how we get to that point
um this started with
because your heavenly father is perfect
be perfect as your heavenly father is
perfect
part of that perfection is that god
already
exists within love within god's self
so trinity there's also a greek word
there was also often used
pericresis it means to dance around they
thought of it as the dance of three
meaning god was already in this loving
giving
and receiving relationship with god's
self
and so why is it that god's light can
shine on the just and
unjust god's reign is there for the good
and the bad
because god is already in perfect loving
relationship within god's self
so i don't have to be god that's not mad
because you didn't recognize god
god is not mad because you didn't show
god proper glory i don't know why we
chose to make god such a racist i mean
such a narcissist who focuses on his
glory all the time but we did
um but god doesn't have to do those
things because god
already exists in this dance of love
with god's self and so a
good first place for us to start in
forgiveness is to just
enter into that flow
i love the psalms especially where it
talks about if i were to go to the place
of the dead you are there
wherever i go god you were there so
there's no place i can go where i can
escape god
so even right here and right now i can
enter into this dance of love
internally so i don't have to wait for
lance to get it right
and i would feel much better if lance
was a more supportive husband blah blah
blah
i can enter directly into this internal
pericaresis
this dance of love that's already
happening inside of me
god's presence already there and it's an
opportunity for me to enter into that
and in that i find that affirmation i
find all of those things
but it happens internally
and then it becomes a thing that we can
share with everyone then
that dance happening in me connects with
lance connects with karen connects with
gary and we just keep going
and now we're right back to where we
started i can love my enemy
i can love my friend because that dance
just goes around with everybody
and that's the dance going on with
everybody all right so let's do just a
quick cliff's notes recap
because i know i tend to spray a lot of
stuff at one time
so the goal is full inclusion why
because god is fully inclusive this is
where jesus
started the whole thing love your
enemies as well as your friends and your
neighbors
why because that's what god does and so
that's our goal because if we want to be
children of god then we act like god
forgiveness is the only path to true
inclusion
i can try anything else but it doesn't
work and we we
all know this like we even know
the people who go out and like you're
super progressive now and that's good
and you've learned
and you've grown but now i have to go
back and i have to hate all the
conservative people
like it's just such a weird concept
as opposed to forgiveness now out of
forgiveness
i can grow i can progress i can do all
those things which are fantastic
but it also doesn't mean that i have to
exclude you so forgiveness is the only
path
forgiving the world forgiving god
for not being what we want it need it or
feel it should be
uh forgiveness doesn't withdraw or
exclude but instead
wisely brings about long-term change or
growth
um so for that means that forgiveness
doesn't mean that i'm like the old wise
man on the heel who's too good for
everyone
and i've basically just kind of excluded
myself because i'm so wise and
i'm so at peace i can't be around the
people
it's actually the opposite from what
we've seen
change happens over years and years
and years and years and i think that's
just how humanity will always be
we've seen large changes in in just in
america in how we
race and how we view human sexuality
and it's fantastic we see the
progression happening
but it's slow it's slow
and it's bound to be slow because that's
the only way you can include everyone
so when i don't forgive and this is my
worst habit i can just move fast
and if you don't get it sucks for you
moving on
but real change is always slow
because although these three people may
get it
we don't get to abandon the other
thousand who are still working through
what they feel and their own
insecurities and how they grew up it's
long
and it's slow and forgiveness gives us
the ability to stick in for the long run
and lastly forgiveness always starts by
participating
in the inner dance
all right and so i try to give people
some time for questions
normally people come up after and
they're like i have a specific instance
of this really horrible thing to happen
to me like how do you explain that
um and i understand all those things
feelings are rough
and so if you do have questions feel
free
also feel free to catch me after um so
let's read our prayer together uh this
is the prayer of confession that we
always read
at our church after sermons um it's all
about uh
confessing to god how we have failed to
live in good community with each other
so i don't want you to take it and make
it about all the horrible person that
you've been and god forgive me and set
me back on the right path
but there are all these ways in which
god has made us for love and inclusion
and we just fail to do it
and that's okay one of the best ways
that we can exist in union together is
that we
actually all admit that together and
then we just stay on the road
so i'll start us off and if you will
just keep reading along
god of compassion and mercy you sent us
your son
as the savior of the world and told us
to love one another
as much as you loved us yet we struggle
to love each other
we have a hard time loving those who are
not like us
who disagree with us or who ask us to
face the truth about ourselves
you told us to love one another because
love is from god
and we often do not love those we think
are dirty
hungry lost or undesirable
it is written that perfect love casts
out fear
and yet we are afraid afraid for our
safety
our wallets and how others perceive us
forgive us god
and show us how to love the way you
command us to love
release us from our judgment and our
fear
open our hearts so that they might
receive your perfect love for us
and offer it to the world and friends
the good news is this
love is from god and we are loved by god
in creation god has forgiven
of god's self and we are forgiven
to do this song and it's probably one
that you may or may not be familiar with
um i hadn't heard it a lot
so don't feel like you need to sing
along i'm not even sure that i provided
lyrics for the guys because really what
i want us to do during this time
is just um think about the things that
aaron just shared with us
and take a moment to be introspective
and
to listen to your own thoughts and
feelings and maybe
names or people that came to mind while
he was talking because
this is something we all struggle with
on one level or another just because
that's human
nature um and so i just thought it might
be nice for us to take a moment and just
listen to gary
and um allow god to you know speak to
you or just listen to things that are
coming up inside of you
and acknowledge them and just kind of
stay in that same posture of the words
that we just spoke together
just confessing and allowing god to do
work in our hearts
i tried to hold you like a secret
wouldn't let go i wouldn't let go
deep down i knew i couldn't keep it
wouldn't you know wouldn't you know
sometimes you climb to watch the sunset
lose to the rain lose to the rain
[Music]
i stood there waiting at your doorstep
you never came you never came
i forgive you i forgive you i forgive
you i
even if i don't know how
yes i forgive you i forgive you i
forgive you i
i will come to lay it all
[Music]
down you wouldn't stop to let me
help you you had to go
you had to go
so many things i want to tell you
you'll never know you'll never know
cause i forgive you i forgive you i
forgive you right
even if i don't know how
yes i forgive you i forgive you i
forgive you i
i will learn to lay it all down
yes i will learn to lay it all down
[Music]
a friend ran into you on friday
you're doing fine you're doing fine
says i'm just stuck inside the replay
just give it time just give it time
yes i forgive you i forgive you i
forgive you i
even if i don't know how
yes i forgive you i forgive you i
[Music]
i catch myself inside the mirror
what do i see what do i see
[Music]
i see my sin my shame my past regrets
looking at me looking at me
yes i forgive you i forgive you i
forgive you bye
even if i don't know how
yes i forgive you i forgive you i
forgive you i
i will learn
[Applause]
that was beautiful thanks gary and thank
you aaron
what a great message i feel like that's
one
for the whole world like yeah so
good so much to think about in chew on i
hope that you'll do that this week
take some time to think about what aaron
said
think about the words to the songs that
we sang tonight especially
um sorry we have our own story of
forgiveness so that
just brings up yeah
so thanks babe for making me cry
anyways um i'm so glad that you joined
us tonight
thank you to those uh that are watching
online as well
erin's message will be online it's
captured so you can go back and watch it
again
i know i'm going to do that so i want to
go back and get definitely those cliff
notes
as well as some of the other things that
he talked about
so good to have you with us good to have
you here too lance
just a couple things to wrap up
any of those that are visiting for the
first time either here or online
we have cards uh out in the lobby and
you can also comment online
uh just put your name and contact
information
and we would love to get in contact with
you personally this coming week
please don't leave here without talking
to somebody or getting prayer
if you need that forgiveness is hard to
do in a vacuum it's hard to do in
isolation so we need community for that
and that's what we're here for
lastly i want to leave you all with a
benediction as you go out
into the world so if all of you stand
if you're able to do so
you are a child of god
this is true on your best day and on
your worst day
it's true for those that are around you
right now and it's true for all of those
out in the world
so as you go out into the week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows
and everything in between go with the
assurance
that you are loved you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend those same
gifts of unconditional love
and grace to everyone you come in
contact with this week
be blessed and we hope to see you back
here next sunday
creative productions you name it
if your name
[Music]
is
so